bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur rtl
avez vous été à la manifestation à cet
après-midi et quelle a été votre point
de vue sur le déroulé de cette
manifestation
mais bon soir va écouter
effectivement j'étais à la manifestation
et le déroulement boîtes etc comme
toutes les manifestations ça se passe
plutôt bien et on a toujours des moments
où bas ça va casser mais bon ça c'est
depuis le début de vie depuis tout temps
j'ai envie de vous dire mais j'ai été
frappé par contre par le nombre de
personnes qui étaient présentes
franchement pour un manifestant comme
moi et sur quoi gilet jaune ça c'était
vraiment une très belle journée de
manifestations d'autant qu'en tant que
gilet jaune vous avez subi vous
directement ce qu'on appelle maintenant
communément les violences policières de
voir autant de monde finalement réunis
après ce qui s'est passé dans le 17e
arrondissement le tabassage de ce
producteur de musique et cette fameuse
réforme de la loi sécurité globale et
l'article 24
finalement ça fait partie de c'était
l'un des combats que vous veniez vous
avant avant tout le monde
ben complètement nous est sûre les
jeunes aient été nous étions des
précurseurs dans ce domaine on a
commencéà dans un premier temps à filmer
parce que justement les médias
mainstream ne parlait pas du tout de ce
mouvement qui était juste exceptionnel
et qui 2 qui aujourd'hui pour moi
restera historique
donc on a commencé à faire des live pour
pouvoir diffuser un petit peu les
informations faire comprendre un petit
peu aux citoyens français
les raisons pour lesquelles nous étions
dehors et une fois que nous avons que
nous avons commencé nous avions pardon
était donc médiatiser malheureusement
les médias mainstream diffusé absolument
pas la réalité de ce qui se passait sur
le terrain à quoi donc nous voilà on
april nous avons pris nous avions pris
les devants pardon
et du coup nous avons commencé à filmer
tout ce qui se passait donc des milliers
de là il est là la réalité commencé à à
émerger d'ailleurs les médias main
stream pendant très très longtemps
refusé complètement l'idée des violences
policières
ça je m'en souviens très bien j'étais
sur les plateaux et pour eux c'était
juste inacceptable que mène le prononcer
oui tout à fait et justement quand vous
voyez donc toutes ces personnes qui sont
mobilisées aujourd'hui est ce que vous
vous êtes vous manifestez toujours avec
un gilet jaune ou pas et comment est ce
que vous êtes perçu un parent retard ces
autres manifestants aujourd'hui
alors écoutez c'est alors moi j'ai pas
manifester aujourd'hui que gilet jaune à
je ne l'avais pas depuis pas mal de
temps je ne le met pas justement je sais
on en revient toujours au même fait ça
reconnaît quand même dans un pays dit
démocratique
on nous a logiquement on peut aller
manifester vécu la manière dont on le
souhaite mais c'est pas possible
si vous êtes gilet jaune c'est pas
possible surtout vous pouvez vous
habiller comme vous voulez pour le coup
c'est pas c'est pas ça le problème mais
à part juste le gilet je ne mettais pas
de jaune sur vous parce que là pour le
coup les deux leurs policiers là vous
allez les connaître et c'est certain
donc c'est la question qu'on pose
effectivement puisque quand on entend au
cours de cette manifestation dans
l'après midi les autorités qui redoute
est évidemment les casseurs et on a
entendu aussi les casseurs et gilet
jaune donc vous êtes associé à ces
casseurs finalement au cours des
manifestations qu'il y a eu de votre
côté et toujours aujourd'hui vous êtes
perçu négativement vous le comprenez
écouter oui je le comprends dans le sens
où les gie les jeunes autre façon c'est
le mouvement social qui a effrayé comme
jamais un autre mouvement scotia a
effrayé un président et son gouvernement
ils sont vraiment c'est ils ont une peur
bleue de ce mouvement social parce
qu'ils ont bien vu que les citoyens
français était clairement décidé à
reprendre
leur destin en main il n'était plus
question d'aller travailler et rentrer
chez soi pour ceux qui le peuvent pas
parce que je rappelle quand même qu'il
ya beaucoup de français aujourd'hui en
2020 travaille durement et dorment dans
leurs véhicules
donc vous voyez il ya un moment donné
ils ont eu un bras ils sont dix ces
citoyens là qui sont dans la rue qui ont
vécu leur gilet jaune
maintenant ils sont prêts à tout
d'ailleurs il ya là des pierres qui
avait dit justement les premiers
violence et vous il avait déjà dit en
son temps et c'est toujours vrai
aujourd'hui
certes hier moment donné vous savez
contre les personnes ne peuvent plus
sous-entendu les autorités exactement
par les autorités moi je te parle pas je
pense plus à ce qui donne les ordres
vous savez moi j'en veux plus comment
monsieur castanet a par exemple monsieur
rivaux au président de la république
lui-même et au préfet l'allemand de des
massacres qu'ils ont créés que aux
policiers eux-mêmes c'est-à-dire un
policier c'est tout simplement en lui
dit tu fais ça tu le fais tu ne fais pas
il ne le fait pas d'ailleurs pour à
titre d'exemple vous si vous vous
souvenez bien au début des jeux du
mouvement des gilets jaunes
lorsqu'il ya eu la grande bataille on va
dire aux champs-elysées rappelez vous il
y avait des forces de l'ordre n'ont pas
bougé il n'avait il avait eu l'ordre de
ne pas bouger ils n'ont pas bougé
voilà et plus le temps passait et les
ordres devenait de plus en plus clair
c'est il faut la doctrine était de tabac
c'est tout le monde il faut effrayer les
gilet jaune afin qu'il ne puisse plus
revenir dans la rue nous n'avons pas une
doctrine
on se pose souvent la question quant à
la conduite à tenir pour les forces de
l'ordre soient ne pas trop intervenir
une manière plutôt plutôt moins
répressive ça c'est un réel mode horde
que vous avez senti ces différences de
de stratégie en tout cas des forces de
l'ordre suivant les nombreuses
manifestations vous avez
auquel vous avez participé encore que
oui au début du mouvement des gels et
jaune 17 novembre par exemple il ya on
pouvait discuter avec des policiers ils
nous répondent et voilà on était
d'accord ou pas d'accord mais en tout
cas on pouvait communiquer et sa apaisé
clairement toutes les foules et c'est
alors parce qu il nous répondait on
pouvait parler avec eux lorsque un
manifestant souhaité se retirer de la
manifestation parce qu'il trouvait que
ça à ça se bouscule un petit peu trop
autres de lacrymogènes il nous orienter
allez-y par là bas ou là le temps
passant c'était plus un an ils vous
répondent pas du tout il vaut méprise
si vous leur parlez de trop il n'hésite
en aucun cas vous matraqué à vous
balayer enfin après les images vous les
connaissez peut-être même mieux que moi
puisque rt france est un média qu'on
voit surtout les sur toutes les
manifestations vous êtes là constamment
depuis le début vous je pense aussi à
tout média que vous avez reçu aussi
précédemment
voilà c'est des images dans tout le
monde se souvient de façon à vous
d'aider des personnes âgées qui se
faisait tabasser
enfin il faisait vraiment plus de 7 et
c'était vraiment la foire la fois où il
faisait ce qu'il voulait donc j'ai bien
vu la différence au début où il nous
parlait communiquer avec nous il ya la
pente on y parlait plus il faisait que
de frapper quoi merci beaucoup il est
organiste d'avoir répondu ce soir en
direct à nos questions sur rt france